foreign
Financial infidelity for the third time
and I feel like I have broken my husband
into pieces
[Music]
what's going on this is John with the Dr
John Maloney show I'm so grateful that
you are joined us
that you are are joined us you have
joined us that you have joined us this
is a linguist show about how to
pronounce words this is the Dr John
deloney show a show about your mental
health a show about relationships uh
work stuff school stuff whatever you got
going on in your life
I'm here to walk alongside you and we
will figure out what we can do next what
you can do next in your life the purpose
of this show is very simple
um I want to take years of experience
years of academic training years of
sitting in the trenches with people and
provide clear Direct
simple unfiltered ways that people
regular folks who are just trying to do
their life just like me just like a dad
and a husband trying to figure it out a
homeowner and a neighbor and someone who
sends my kids to public school we're
just trying to figure it out I want to
provide a clear path forward in this new
third way because when we look this way
and we look that away it's chaos chaos
chaos and I'm done with it I'm done with
it I'm getting out of the aquarium I'm
I'm getting I'm unplugging from The
Matrix so this show is about finding a
new Third Way a new third way to live to
be well to be whole to interact and find
joy and peace again to actually sleep
all night actually drink coffee in the
morning just because I want to not
because I have to
it's about changing everything sometimes
and sometimes it's just about making a
few tweaks but my promises I'm gonna
tell you the truth even when I don't
know I'll say I don't know and I'm going
to walk alongside you and we're going to
figure it out if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k
and please send these shows to everyone
that you know anyone you think would
benefit from it if you think man
somebody needs this a word here or some
insights here or my friend's been asking
about this or about ADHD or narcissism
or what they can do with their marriage
or whatever's going on send these shows
to everybody you know and please just
take 30 seconds and give us a like a
five-star review
um or a subscribe just hit the Subscribe
button it means the world all right
let's go out to Dana in Salt Lake City
what's up Dan and the Utes how we doing
doing well thank you how are you I'm
dude we're just having a party having a
party great
so what's up how can I help okay I am
hey Dana do me a favor talk directly
into your phone for me okay
okay all right can you hear me better
yes a little bit better there you go go
for it
I'm a 63 year old grandmother I've been
divorced
three times I've had several
relationships since my last divorce that
have not worked out
um I cannot keep even friends although
my children I have five children I get
along great with them they're adult
children my grandchildren I get along
with great
it's the personal relationships that I
have with
uh marriages
um with by uh trying to find the right
man I don't know if
if I am the narcissist
um I don't believe that I am but I am
afraid but I might be I I cannot keep
even friendships
I am sad that
I can't do that right now but I've been
trying to get back with even my best
friend that I've had for years that does
not want anything to do with me
what's been the Catalyst for number one
thank you for your vulnerability like
what you're saying is hard to say out
loud right
um when we get married
we at some level deep in our bones say
this is forever and you said that three
times
and yes
we think that good grief when we were 12
or we were no before that we were four
we could barely remember to go to the
bathroom but we can always have friends
and then when we're adults we there's an
extra sense of Shame and what a loser
right so it's a bold Brave step to say
that out loud so I'm proud of you I'm
proud of you for saying Out Loud Let's
go uh let's let's divide these up what
happened in your marriages if you were
to look at all three of them and say
Here's a common denominator across all
three what would that be
um
the common denominator would be
me as a so I've always figured it's it's
me I had to kind of look and say you
know yeah it's me so what is the issue I
think that it is
when things start going wrong
and I try to voice my opinion or I say
something but if I don't agree with you
um I get so upset why why what what
happened in your life that made you
circle the wagons on this idea that if
you're wrong you're worthless
I don't know it came from somewhere
I know it had to have been I had a great
childhood
so I I don't know
I uh
I guess my child because I could
remember I came from a very religious
family I wanted out of the house fast
because I did not want want that
lifestyle hold on I'm gonna stop you
right there you did not have a great
childhood then
because yeah
I I often take other Ops the opposite
call how do I get my kid out of here and
to quote my friend Dr Henry Cloud I've
got to often teach parents how to give
their kids problems like rent and bills
because their house is their life is so
great at home that they don't want to
leave both relationally and with needs
being met yours was the opposite you
couldn't wait to go
correct so carrying around this
narrative that everything was great and
wonderful and Grand is not true
somewhere along the way being wrong
was dangerous
somewhere along the way somebody took
away your
um Power and what I mean by that is
um it could be as simple as you didn't
want to hug every one of those uncles
and you had to line up and hug them all
and they'd kiss you on the mouth and on
the ear when you were a little girl and
you didn't want to and you squirmed and
you tightened up your body and you got
in trouble for it not them
and you learned at a young age that what
you want does not matter
what matters is that Mom and Dad look
good in this little system that we're in
and Dan I'm just making this up am I
close or not
you're very close I I rebelled at a very
young age just to
yeah
and often we we look at oh man
we look at children especially younger
children that quote unquote Rebel and we
want to beat them down and blame them
instead of looking at their little
bodies that are not developed yet and
say what about this system that we have
dropped this child into
is so sick that this child's body is
saying get out get out get out get out
get out
well and now you're 63. and for 35 years
you're willing to lose it all
for being right
correct for quote unquote winning
congratulations you see what I'm saying
yes yes
not working for me no there you go there
you go
um I think the fact that you're asking
this question would suggest
um just off the top that you're not a
narcissist but let's run down the list
just for fun do you believe the world
was just like was designed for you that
ultimately people you are mostly smarter
than everybody that you are around
you're probably more or less more
beautiful than other people
um one day you're going to be more
successful than everybody around you is
that is that how you see the world
no
do people in the world exist for your
pleasure
no
what are you entitled to
besides being right
nothing really I can't
that no entitlements seriously yeah let
me ask you this when when you when one
of your husbands was to say
we're not making out enough
and you felt that rage I I call it that
inner thermometer just shoots up
right and it explodes out the top
and you point at him and say how dare
you we make out all the time and this
and this and this
yes do you feel like he was stupider
than you or do you feel like he was
being honest and you were having to
defend yourself
um
we're
what's the hell picking on me like they
were trying to
yeah but it was it was me here you're
bad you're you're not doing this you're
not doing that you're not giving me what
I need so here I am so then I feel like
I have to defend myself
and I
um so the the
your body has some pretty simplistic
just pretty simple responses to trauma
correct it'll run
it'll turn and pick up a stick and fight
and it's it's amazing I've got a
gigantic 13 year old son who's very very
strong we wrestle we got we got
wrestling mats upstairs we wrestle he's
very strong but when it comes down to
like confrontation
yes his natural inclination he's very
very fast he will take off
he leans away my seven-year-old daughter
who's
0.3 pounds I could sneeze and knock her
over
if we get sideways she squares up and
gets ready to throw down
so there's nothing about gender there's
nothing about strength there's nothing
about size it's just how bodies respond
and for some reason
your body
um responds to somebody challenging you
as an act of War
he said I could beat him up with my
mouth
and what I want to ask you is what is
that got you
enough it's it's gotten me
to divorce I it's are you done with it
I am so done with it I'm in a
relationship now and trying so hard to
make this work okay I'm gonna tell you
right now you're you're already doomed
to fail again
here's why here's why
you're trying to constrict it even
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter until it
snaps
oh wow what I want you to do is to open
your hands completely and just freaking
let go Dana
let go
the more you have tried over the course
of your life to not screw something up
the Tighter and Tighter it has become
and then when he inevitably says
something that's going to be of
Confrontation why do you put the trash
in did you not did you not get this
thing why didn't you pick me up when you
said you were going to be there
is no margin it just goes bam it snaps
it's over I'm out bye
yep
that's it so let's do the exact opposite
here's what I mean
when you feel your body setting off
again and you've done this long enough
now and actually you are super just so
you know you are 20 counseling sessions
down the road have you been to therapy
before
yes okay you're you're way down the road
which is impressive it's really
incredible
so I want to tell you you're right at
the door here okay I want you to carry
around a little journal with you
okay and don't even use your notes app
because I want you to take the time the
kinetic time to write this thing down
okay all right and when you feel your
body starting to set off I want you to
hold your breath
hold it
for one two three seconds and remember
that knucklehead on some podcast you
talked to one day
okay
okay and all I want you to do is to look
at the person you're about to explode on
and say I need three minutes I need five
minutes
and then I want you to walk outside and
I want you to write down what you are
about to say to that person write it
down in your Journal
okay
is that cool
that's way cool yes and next anytime
y'all are about to get into a discussion
I want you to about a thing whatever the
thing is I want you all to sit on the
same side of the table
and take a little note card and put in
the middle of the table thing that we're
talking about
that way all the energy and frustration
and rage and anger all those things that
come up are gonna go to this thing
not to you and not to back to him
remember this in your soul
if you win and he loses you both lose
oh wow that's
awesome okay yeah that's oh great and he
wins and you lose you both lose
right so the goal here is to what what
is the thing that is going to push our
relationship a little bit further down
the road just just a couple of inches
and then a couple inches beyond that and
then a couple inches beyond that
right yeah right
wow hey here's your new identity okay
okay I want you to say these words out
loud
I'm Dana and I no longer go to no let's
let's don't even do that
I'm Dana and I'm a person who seeks
peace
I'm Dana I'm a person who seeks peace
I'm Dana I don't fight anymore
I'm Dana
I'm Dana and I will love you till the
end of time
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to work in service of those three
identities we're just gonna work
backwards on it what do I have to do way
Upstream so that I can love you till the
end of time that means I gotta like when
you are with this person say it's pretty
obvious that I can uh like I I have a
hurricane inside of me that can be
Unleashed on from time to time and so I
want to try to do something different
now that I'm 63
yeah when I feel the hurricane coming I
want to step away so I want you to know
that I love you I'm in I like dating you
and I want to protect you and this
relationship and myself and so sometimes
I'm gonna say I need five minutes
went to some more on uh podcaster told
me I need five minutes and then I'm
gonna write down and then I'm gonna come
back in and I might write something down
on a note card and put it in the middle
of our table and you're gonna think
you're dating a crazy person but we are
getting on the road to being well
because I'm not fighting anymore
I'm seeking peace
I'm seeking peace and I'm gonna seek
peace in relationship
I
I've got high hopes for you Dana
if you commit I'm never going to war
again I'm done going to war and once I
take War off the table once I take rage
off the table once I take walking away
off the table once I take indignation
off the table
then it leaves only this many other
options like discussions and
communication and I need to go for a
walk and let's go talk to a counselor
about this let's call my sister in
because she can actually hear me or
maybe you call your friends and you say
so sorry
I'm so sorry
I treated you like the demons that have
been hounded me since I was a little
girl and I'm sorry
give me another shot
63 years old it's never too late to turn
it all around I'm so grateful for you
Dana keep me updated on your journey
we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with the licensed
therapist and you can switch therapists
at any time for no additional charge so
find more balance find Wellness with
better help visit betterhelp.com
deloni today to get 10 off your first
month that's a better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to Lynn in
Orlando Florida what's up Lynn
and what are you up to
anything down here in sunny Orlando
well just kick us while we're actually
it's nice in Nashville today so haha
there you go beautiful what's up
uh well well um my call today is really
just based on um I have an adult
daughter
um who in the past has been a little
disgusted
um say that again she's been she's been
what
a bit deceptive
um I don't like crazy I don't like to
say lying but you know just um not being
completely honest with my husband and I
okay can I stop you right there I have a
bad habit of interrupting I know I just
love to get the data points like Okay
um
how long
um well she's 25 now and this is
probably when she went off to school
when she was about 18 or 19.
so 19. and where in the world did she
learn
to not say exactly what it is but to
kind of use other words that kind of
were skirted around it a little bit
that's me joking right now because
you're like I don't want to call her a
liar I just want to call her deceptive
I guess yeah
and her 18 year old mind like I wasn't
hammered I had like two no I had two
drinks
I'm not I wasn't we weren't sleeping
together Mom I just stayed too late yeah
she's so good I just want to point that
out go ahead go ahead yes so well I mean
it was more or less just like
um I guess a year of schooling um she
said she was in class and she was not
um she was uh I guess for her words to
you know to us was that she had this
paralyzing anxiety and couldn't show up
in class so what about that do you not
believe because you don't believe her I
could be telling your voice you don't
believe her I I it's okay if you don't
um I mean I do believe her um just based
on I've had
um prior to that she did have an episode
when she was younger like where she did
cutting
um not not horrible I guess it's not
good or bad but I mean she did do it she
didn't tell us about it but I did see it
because
um you know I'm pretty observant I have
there's four of them so
um I was you know anyway so I did notice
that she was doing that um brought it up
to her because I saw it um she was very
forthcoming and I you know she I took
her to see a therapist and um I guess we
I thought we had moved on I didn't see
any more indication of that she was at
the point you know at that time I
thought she was being very open
um
but then
um anyway so moving forward she did go
to we thought she wanted to go to school
um we you know prepared for her to do
that as parents do and uh lo and behold
when you know we needed a verification
that she had been in school she had to
come clean so she didn't do it willingly
she just did it because it was basically
by the Fall
um so coming to the present day
um she uh was living in Tallahassee
still
um
another guy while she was there and they
were in a relationship her um quite some
time and just recently she told us some
pretty troubling news which is quite
personal but
um for the sake of just it was not good
and but she was the whole time she was
still lying to us about like what she
was doing and what her life was all
about so we were I I guess painstakingly
we were proud of her because you know
from what she
um what she was doing while she was in
school
um you know we were back on that trust
train again trying to
trust her again and then lo and behold
like within like the last couple of
months um
you know had that kind of news
um but so
now she's like she got out of it she was
with a boy she was with the boyfriend
and they broke up
um she made some really really bad
financial decisions with him
um very expensive financial decisions
and so she's no longer with him but now
she's with
um a new boyfriend and
um she's doing a lot of behavior like I
said she's you know smoking daily she's
drinking more than she has ever she's
never been a big drinker that I know of
um
and I'm just concerned with her current
state how old is she Lynn
she's 25.
and you have four other kids where does
she fall what order
she's the oldest oldest
and tell me about Dad
um
just like who he is or what kind of
father he is or okay so he uh
I mean she's a lot like him so I guess
she just you know she's the kind of
wanted to tell me about him okay so he
doesn't like to he's kind of likes to
live in Oblivion like if there's you
know there's a lot of issues that he has
that he likes to push him underneath the
carpet
um
such as
maybe you've spent the last 25 years of
your relationship covering up for this
dude I'm asking you just tell me about
him
um
not emotionally available okay
so but very sensitive like yeah yeah yes
okay so I wrote down two words when you
started talking
the two words are connection and
pressure
the behaviors you're describing with
your daughter behaviors I've seen
thousand times working with college
students for two decades
here's what it is
a young child screaming
for the two adults in their life in her
life
not to
um
play with all that's a part of but to
connect do you see me
and a disregulated child that is not
fully plugged in
will try to plug into a hundred
different things when you're trying to
plug in that pressure will build and
build and build and I can control it
sometimes through
eating or not eating I can control it
through cutting I can control it through
athletic achievement I can control even
through Straight A's
It ultimately manifests itself into high
high anxiety
and what makes anxiety go away weed
alcohol
Percocet it stops it for a while until
it kills you
right
buying things what else intimate
relationships
so all of the behaviors I mean it's just
she's following a track
the second thing is is
the word sensitive it has such a
negative connotation in our culture
which I just hate I am extra sensitive
to certain things all of us are some
people are extra sensitive too how much
jalapenos they can have in their queso
some are extra sensitive to they walk
into a room and can just feel
something's off
um I have a weird I can walk up to
somebody and look at them and say you're
not okay you don't have to talk to me
about it but I want you to know that I
see you and I care about you and just
I'll walk away nine times out of ten
that person will reach out and be like I
don't know who you are you weird
sorcerer but there's a sensitivity okay
great
when you have an older child who is born
highly sensitive
and then they get the weight of the
family put on them because Dad's
unavailable
it's trying to hold like just think
about holding like workout plates above
your head and your arms start shaking
and shaking and shaking
and so the question is that as a 25 year
old isn't it here's what I'm gonna tell
you she doesn't need any more advice
she doesn't need any more threats or any
more if you just do this is then this
then this is because there's been a
continual
my relationship to you her dad's
relationship to her
um has been contingent on performance
if she doesn't do a thing or she does do
a thing then you get us
you get our money our support our love a
seat at our table
see what I'm saying I do and so
the only way through it is a complete
and utter reversal of how y'all have
done it and if Dad won't be involved
dad's not going to be involved but she's
gonna have to hear you say those words
he's available but I mean like he like I
don't know how like he's not present but
not available which I think is actually
more caustic to a kid
okay an absent father a father who moves
away I mean you can look at the data
it's it's really damaging but a dad who
sits on the couch and stares off into
space her dad who stares at his laptop
makes a kid insane because the kid is
wondering what is so great because it's
all relationship for a child that's how
they see the world so they want to know
what is so appealing and beautiful and
wonderful about that laptop that they
don't have
you take a sensitive what is so
important about that client why is that
client so much more beautiful than me
Dad
and she will try to answer that question
forever and ever and ever and when
you're 12 you you don't have any
resources to answer questions and it
just bottles and traps and traps and
traps and traps and that's when cutting
goes it lets some of the steam out
yeah that's how she describes it I mean
I did you know I mean we actually have a
very
I mean they're always very forthcoming
eventually with me but it's usually when
it's you know
come information like like they don't
hardly have a choice
um
you're a conflating relationship with
information
okay y'all get y'all y'all pass
information back and forth to each other
well I know how to take like was if she
says something if she tells me that
something is her reality or like this is
her situation I don't know to really
trust her because every time that why
I totally trust you I'm not going to
give you any money that's not where
we're at right now right but I hear you
and I'm so heartbroken for you and you
are always welcome at our house
yes and I believe that they do believe
that because we've had that so many
times I know they
they know that they can
um come here and that we're always you
know here to help them I mean
um
I don't know what this you know she just
says stuff and then she just like it
comes out and you're like well why I
don't understand why you would do that
or why you would think that was okay or
you know what I mean and then
I don't know how can you if I'm not
articulating it correctly but no no
you're articulating it great I'm trying
to think of the right way to say it
um I just want you to look at your
relationship with your oldest daughter
your baby girl
yeah and ask if
a a relational approach of judgment
at all cost what does that got you
I would suggest trying a path of
curiosity and love over judgment she
knows you don't approve of what she's
doing you don't have to keep saying that
right what she's desperate for is you to
take her out for coffee and say I've got
some things I never told you
and you tell her about that boy that was
hurt you deeply before you met her dad
and how hard it has been to be in
relationship with somebody that you love
deeply but who is emotionally absent
and maybe you didn't cut and maybe you
didn't fill in the blank but you did
have some coping strategies because
you've made it this far
and in some ways you've been a single
parent with a guy sitting on the other
end of the couch
you know what she's going through
and sometimes when I see something in my
son I know what he's doing because I did
the exact thing I'm over overzealous
about it because I don't want him to
hurt like I did
and in the process I push him away
because he doesn't have a context for my
opinion
and so when I say connecting that her
behavior is like more or less because of
the relationship between her like she
has with her dad or
like I mean like is there like I don't
know I guess what I'm saying is you see
the world in cause and effect either or
this because that everything for you is
an algorithm and I'm telling you it's
way more complex than that it so
a thousand different things could have
led to this moment what I'm telling you
at this point is it doesn't matter
I'm telling you is you have a 25 year
old daughter who is desperate to know
her mom and to know that her mom sees
her and loves her and trusts her
because you say my kids know they can
come home
your daughter's Behavior over the last
five years suggests she doesn't know
that or she knows she can come home but
it's not worth it
because we're gonna have to do this and
have all these lectures and discussions
and why are we doing all these things
and I'm not saying those are all bad
what I'm saying is
she needs to know you're a human not a
not in a spreadsheet
that doesn't make sense because the with
everything that's you know going on or
you know I mean I don't make the whole
like I mean we we get together quite
frequently but I don't talk to her about
it I'm if she brings it up I may say
well where are you what you know with
that just you know do you are you making
any Headway you know so you can get out
of that situation so you can move
forward and she's like I just don't want
to talk about it with you right so I
don't know
okay and I just don't know in your mind
first does she know that we're available
there
in your mind
a conversation means you are supporting
her decisions
holding your hand across the table at a
coffee shop and looking in the eyes and
telling her I've never cut but I've done
this
okay I've had to survive too and I'm not
I'm telling you that because I've hidden
this from you because I want to be the
strong one and those days are over now
I love you I love you too much to let
you go through this by yourself
and no I'm not gonna move my values my
values are here because of what I've
experienced
but if all we needed was
um for the good life was a textbook we
would just read one
right yeah but we need relationship
and
I my guess is you and I could talk for
another five hours you've probably had
to turn some of that off in your life to
survive
and not survive not to death but survive
sanity wise
yes you're not wrong about that
and there's a terrifying fear that if
you open that door even a crack to
somebody especially to your daughter
that you will lose control never be able
to close that door back
am I right
you're not wrong
you can't even say it I love it you
can't say the words you are right and I
was wrong
so good what do you think of on those
things so listen listen yes
here's what your daughter knows
okay okay can I just can I can I just
cut to the chase real direct but I want
to say it that's exactly what I want I
just thought you and I are having fun at
this point okay but I'm being serious
yeah okay your daughter knows you're not
telling the truth too she learned it
from you
okay she learned that we've got to hide
certain things so that we can stay in
relationship with people so that we can
eat so we cannot get hurt so we can stay
safe so that somebody will help us with
our tuition because we can't tell the
full story and we learned it from Mom
because mom had to put part of herself
in a closet so that she could survive
and the only way through that is for you
to open the closet door and show your
daughter a little bit of what's in there
not all the not guts and Gore and all
that kind of stuff
right
but she's gotta know her mom knows her
Anne loves her anyway
and I if I'm so here's what I'm telling
you if I'm you I would sit down and have
some sort of conversation about this
I have tried to Love You Through giving
you advice and wisdom for so long
those days are over if you ask me I'm
going to tell you
but I'm going to invite you in I I want
you to know there's always a standing
offer for my wisdom and my advice for
whatever that's worth
from this point forward I want my
daughter back
and I'm gonna go first
there are some stories about me that you
don't know
that I want you to know
okay I can do that can you
yes I actually can I mean it's got
kids could try to be the strong person
for your kids and
sometimes being the strong person is
comes across as highly inauthentic and
deceptive
or to say it another way sometimes the
strongest most powerful thing you can do
there's still somebody I'm not okay
literally like physically speaking the
hardest I've ever been hugged was from
an active seal
he'd gotten back from deployment had
some challenges
and was hugging me so hard I couldn't
breathe
they were weeping so hard they couldn't
that was strength
that was bravery that was power
that's what I'm talking about
and that person's a close friend to this
day
[Music]
your daughters got all the rules she
knows she's got all the values she knows
and I'm not saying you become a doormat
not at all you hold true to your value
thank you
it's time that your daughter got to meet
her mom
and it's time you look her now and say
I'm sorry
I didn't know what to do so I went to
rules I went to regulations
and I pushed you away I'm sorry from
this point forward I want my daughter
back
[Music]
thank you so much for being bravelyn
we'll be right back
all right we are back let's go back to
Salt Lake City and talk to Megan what's
up Megan
wow that's way better that's fantastic
that's good that's awesome
what's up kid
um so I have recently failed myself my
spouse my marriage by
um committing Financial infidelity for
the third time
and I feel like I have really just
like broken
my husband into pieces and I I recognize
that this is completely my fault and
It's A coping mechanism that I use when
I'm in distress and I
I just really need to figure out how to
how to best help the situation and get
trust again and and work towards a
better future because he's
been
um forgiving enough to give me another
chance even though I don't really
deserve that I feel do you believe that
or is that just like a thing you say
many times and I know that it's
so hurtful it's like he's he even
expressed me it's like being actually
cheated on yeah
um yeah the the conversations I've had
with folks behind closed doors it's very
very similar
just the devastation of it all how bad
how bad is your um how bad has it been
we um paid those off together and and
got debt free and then
um I was doing really well I was
following a budget and and doing other
things to help manage stress and
um other things that were going on
in my life we've had a rough couple of
years
um these last two years because
um several people in my family passed
away
including my mom oh geez I'm sorry yeah
and um so I was doing
in my opinion really well
and um I didn't know
that um I had some health issues
creeping up and had to go off of work
for about 12 weeks just because I was in
a lot of pain and constant headaches and
um a lot of a lot of problems
um relating to that and didn't work and
I didn't know that my credit card
attached to my bank
was still active and so I was
overdrafting on certain things and just
bills and didn't know that that was
coming out of the credit card so that's
kind of what started it all
and I didn't want to come clean about
that because it's embarrassing I just
wasn't paying attention and then it
became a free-for-all
yeah
so let me ask you
um
because even I bet your headaches and
autoimmune
are stemming from
somewhat possibly the same places
I I do know that they I had a brain scan
and they have two brain tumors oh you do
okay all right yeah so what kind of
tumors are they
adenoma and the other one is uh
pineocytoma I'm waiting to get that one
evaluated but the pituitary is benign
okay
and what was the other one uh opinions I
told my it's by the pineal gland yeah
yeah
um
I I would have to sit down and look at
the architecture of where these things a
lot of questions here one of the
questions off the top off the top of my
head like just so
with with that piece of insight
um
it may be that you've got just some
behavioral regulation challenges because
of
like a legitimate brain disorder you've
got stuff going on in your mind you've
got tumors in your head right and so
um
it might be that you've need a healthy
dose of Grace for yourself and somehow
restriction just some big time
roadblocks right similar to like
when my granddad became 85 like he
couldn't drive anymore
and he's not a bad guy but he was going
to run somebody over so he couldn't
drive anymore so
um it had nothing to do with character
had nothing to do with it just like I
can't have debit card anymore can't have
a credit card we can't have it I can't
have access to the bank account because
I've got tumors on my brain that have
some sort of uh relationship to
Behavior regulation that's that's a
thing that could be it
another question I'd have for you is
not knowing that
I would be willing to bet it's somebody
at some point you have a major major in
your bones problem with authority
yeah where does that come from
uh
probably my parents being released
were they insanely strict
um I think most of the problem was being
compared uh to my
older sister who has some ADHD and and
like behavior and not Behavior learning
problems and being told that I was kind
of wasting my potential and
um every time I would like mess up
I would get
um lectured or take privileges taken
away or so so let's let's back out a
little bit lectures happen that's part
of life privilege is getting taken away
that's part of life yeah if you can
honestly look back at your upbringing
and
interactions with Mom and Dad
interactions with brothers and sisters
relationships were contingent on
performance
and when you didn't perform
well then you can't go on the family
whatever or we're all going to the movie
and you got to stay at home
or we're gonna do this thing and you
have to eat outside whatever
it becomes this
to be in here you've got to dance monkey
dance
see what I'm saying and so that behavior
can get transferred to something as
simple as a budget I'm not doing what
you say
I'm not
I can do whatever I freaking want to
because I'm an adult
yeah
and when you the way you're describing
like I'm trying to be good I'm trying to
be good I'm trying to be good you're not
changing your core identity there you're
trying to White Knuckle this thing as
tough as you can and you're gonna fail
every time
yeah and this is the pot talking to the
kettle it's like I'm not having candy
I'm not having candy I'm not eating junk
food I'm not filling the blank yes I am
because I haven't dealt with the core
issues
mm-hmm
so let's take let's take
um
let's take brain tumors off the table
for a second holding that might be part
of the problem okay might be a
significant part of the problem
what if you were able to see a budget as
one of the greatest gifts you could give
to yourself
or let me say it this way my friend Sal
um I've had him on the show several
times he's uh talks about
um diet and exercise with on his show on
the Mind pump show
um he says you can't hate your body
into shape
you can't hate the way you look so bad
and that's why you go to the gym because
then the gym becomes a punishment
and you can only punish yourself so long
before you end up at the buffet again
you can only punish and hate yourself so
long before I'm just not going to the
gym anymore because it's a literal
beating like literally it's a punishment
when I open my eyes and think I love
myself so much I'm gonna go give myself
an hour
of movement exercise doing hard stuff
I'm gonna I give myself an hour that's
how much I love myself
dude my gym time goes an hour and 20
minutes goes an hour I gotta literally
leave my son came down this morning it
was like Dad we gotta go
because I was I was I was giving myself
this gift it wasn't a matter of I gotta
go get it done and I don't always do
that but most of the times it's a gift
right so
it's a matter of changing your
perspective from this budget is
something that constrains me doesn't
treat me like an adult tells me I'm
stupid cuts me off from relationship
just like my I grew up
always it's a comparison thing because
if we had this and the neighbors have
that and they have this and the Joneses
have the instead of then do your
budget's the greatest gift because your
budget's going to help you build wealth
over the long term it's going to keep
you safe in the present and you see what
I'm saying it's just a total refrain
yeah
and then having like
sitting down with your husband once a
week to talk about where we are
financially becomes a gift you give to
yourself
or it becomes a more powerful gift than
another pair of shoes or another
whatever thing it is that you're buying
right yeah that would be nice
have you tried that before
um we actually had a meeting a budget
meeting last night but we've both kind
of been sick so it wasn't super
productive but we plan to do it going
forward can you make those fun
sure here's what I mean
I'm thinking of
um there's families out there so I'm
about to make this weird sorry guys like
strip budget or
um silly budget or joke budget is there
a way to keep it from becoming another
business meeting in the house but we're
gonna have a blast
we're gonna be silly and we're gonna
make it fun and it's a competition who
saves whoever saves the most gets a
thousand dollar bonus like whatever the
thing is
can we turn it into something that you
and your husband can have a blast doing
and you look forward to it
yeah we can totally do that
because here's what I want to do I want
to change the entire ethos around this
thing it's a gift that you are giving
yourself
and with that gift comes High
accountability so I wanted to pretend at
this point
um you are struggling with alcoholism
okay
you're an alcoholic
and it would be foolish of me to tell an
alcoholic just think of a drink as like
a gift to yourself
not as something right that would be
insane
yeah
um
so I think for a season
it would be wise to disconnect yourself
from things
okay to have your husband change the
Amazon Prime account
to change the bank codes to take you and
I'm going to be honest with you there
was a season I gave my debit card to my
wife
I gave myself an allowance we did it
together but I simply could not stop
purchasing things I grew up with a lot
of money and security when I started
getting jobs
it was this compulsion I had
and I've got a bad bad problem with
authority it's tough
[Music]
and it's just it's my body goes to as
soon as it feels a boundary it feels I
need to go hit it for no reason like I
just need to see if this thing holds
hate boundaries hate them
and it wasn't until my wife said you
scare me
and I mean that was it
I don't want to scare you anymore
and that means I've got to put this
thing down because right now I don't
have control over it
see what I'm saying so it's what I'm
telling you is both and you're going to
work on your identity you're going to
work on what this does for us and we're
going to work on the trust rebuild which
is I'm taking my ability to buy things
away
here's what this is going to look like
in real life Megan it's gonna be the
worst
every time you feel that sense of Rage
or entitlement or I'm a grown-up and I I
want you to write that down
okay I'm feeling like I'm a child again
and then you can look at this and say
and I'm chained I'm I'm strengthening
new muscles
I'm changing my family tree here and
that tree starts one decision at a time
and it's gonna be okay it's going to be
uncomfortable listen to me it's gonna be
the worst you're going to drive up to
fill your car up with gas and you are
not going to have cash in your wallet
you're gonna have to leave or Worse
you're gonna have to call your husband
to come get you and you are gonna be out
of your mind
then the next time you won't forget cash
right right
yeah this is the same as if somebody
cheated on somebody I always tell the
person who got cheated on
you you get to lay the ground rules for
trust rebuild you want to see all the
all the email accounts great you'll see
all the text messages every night great
you're gonna do a spot check on the
phone great whatever you got to do and
then I'm going to look at the person who
did the cheating and say are you all in
and I'll ask you Megan are you all in
110 yes okay
from today forward would you ever cheat
with money again
no will you commit with all of your guts
to letting go of this problem with
authority
yes money is just an extension
okay I want you to last little homework
assignment you ready
yeah tonight I want you to get a stop by
Home Depot or something on the way home
from work and I want you to buy a cinder
block just one it'd be like five or six
bucks
okay when you get home I want you to
take out a piece of duct tape or masking
tape and put it on there
and I want you to write a short little
note to your mom and dad about what they
things they used to say to you
one or two things of the way they
treated you
and then I want you to go out in the
backyard I want you to carry it around
I want you to walk around your backyard
carrying it and it's going to get real
real heavy
think about some of those things that
made you so mad when you're a kid
couldn't wait to get out of there
the thing your mom said at your wedding
the thing your dad did right before you
got to get all that stuff yeah and when
you can't carry that brick anymore
I want you to go to the corner of your
backyard
and just set it down
when you set it down I want you to tear
that piece of tape off and you want you
to look at that thing and say I'm not
picking you up again I'm done with those
old stories I'm writing new ones
well okay okay and every time it sounds
simple but every time you start to pick
something up you can think you'll have a
you'll have a moment kind of like a
funeral you'll be able to point to your
backyard and say nope I set this one
down my dad doesn't get a vote anymore
my mom doesn't get a vote anymore nobody
gets a vote anymore except me and my
husband moving forward and your friends
are gonna tell you oh my gosh he took
away your debit card he's the worst he
no no no no I I I set it down I gave it
up
because I'm building new muscles now I'm
working on new things
I don't shop online anymore because my
marriage is more important than that
than my convenience
my husband does the shopping now
because he loves our marriage more than
video game time
whatever y'all got to do to make it work
but let's change let's set down that
stuff you've been carrying for so long
stop it's just up Kerry
let's build something entirely new
something entirely new
so grateful for the call Megan we'll be
right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show one
of my favorite songs in the world from
one of my favorite bands in the world
this is The Killers Mr Brightside and it
goes like this coming out of my cage and
I'm doing just fine I gotta be down
because I want it all and started out
with a kiss how did it end up like this
it was only a kiss and now I'm falling
asleep and she's calling a cab and he's
having a smoke and she's taking a drag
and they're going to bed and my stomach
is sick and it's all in my head
she touches his chest now and he takes
off her dress now
just let me go and I just can't look at
it's killing me and they're taking
control jealousy turning Saints into the
sea swimming through sick lullabies
choking on your Alibis but it's just the
price I pay and Destiny's calling me to
open up my eager eyes because I'm Mr
Brightside love you guys stay in school
don't do drugs peace
[Music]